we begin this morning with what's next
for R&B singer R Kelly and his deepening
legal troubles his management tells us
he'll likely be released from jail today
Kelley was arrested earlier this week
for failing to pay more than one hundred
sixty one thousand dollars in child
support and charged last month with ten
counts of aggravated criminal sexual
abuse
Kelly's arrest came after his explosive
interview with Gayle King on CBS this
morning
he claimed the allegations of abuse
against him are hurting his ability to
support his family
Jericka Duncan is in Chicago outside the
jail where Kelly is being held sharika
good morning good morning r Kelly's team
has been working to put enough money
together for the singer's release now
his publicist says that he was willing
to pay around fifty thousand dollars but
a judge wanted him to come up with the
full amount of money that he owes in
child support
you're gonna haul him into court and say
pay one hundred sixty one thousand
dollars and he's not working so where
did the money come from r Kelly's
publicist echoed a sentiment the R&B
singer told Gayle King earlier this week
that the controversy surrounding him has
become a financial burden what is your
relationship with your children Kelly
returned to jail Wednesday for failing
to dole out more than $160,000 in child
support he posted bond just a week
earlier days after pleading not guilty
to ten counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse waiting for Kelly's return
his two girlfriends as real Clary and
Joycelyn savage what is your
relationship both of you with our Kelly
him that's what it is and we're in a
relationship with him right a very
strong relationship we'll help you yes
savages parents told King that Kelly
brainwashed their daughter and at a news
conference
Clary's father said his daughter's
behavior in the interview with King was
unrecognizable I'll tell you what it is
not my doing the woman she had become
now is like robotic Dominique Gartner
says she used to live with Kelly and the
two women in the docu-series surviving
are Kelly Gardner's mother Michelle
Kramer reunites with Dominique Kramer
says it had been three years since they
saw each other and told us why it took
so long it's like a drug can't get
nobody offshore they gotta be ready to
get off when they want to
we spoke with Chicago sun-times
journalist Jim de Regatas for our
primetime special on our Kelly he's
reported on allegations of Kelly's
sexual contact with underage girls for
nearly 20 years the churches of Chicago
failed the school's failed the press
failed the music industry certainly
failed but everybody failed these young
black girls everybody Kelly continues to
deny all abuse allegations Kelly's
publicist says that his client remains
in good spirits while behind bars and is
looking forward to a speedy trial if
convicted on all charges our Kelly could
face up to 70 years in prison Dana
Jericka thank you very much